aquí tenemos un contenedor de agua
abierto por lo tanto se encuentra a la
presión atmosférica normal también
supongamos que todo lo demás de nuestro
sistema es decir el aire la cantidad de
agua
el contenedor todo se encuentra a 21
grados celsius ahora bien nuestro
contenedor de agua está dividido en dos
cámaras una a la izquierda y otra a la
derecha las cuales están divididas por
una membrana semipermeable es decir es
permeable solo para el agua pero no para
el soluto disuelto en el agua vamos a
decir que en la cámara izquierda tenemos
agua pura
sólo tenemos moléculas de h2o podemos
verlo como agua destilada ahora del lado
derecho no tenemos agua destilada aquí
tenemos un poco de cloruro de sodio
disuelto en el agua y como queremos
agregar cantidades voy a decir que hay
0.25 moles por litro o 0.25 molar de
cloruro de sodio
ahora bien sabemos de manera intuitiva
por nuestro conocimiento de osmosis qué
es lo que le pasará como nuestra
membrana solo es permeable al agua y el
lado derecho es hipotónico con respecto
al lado izquierdo es decir tiene una
concentración mayor de absoluto por lo
tanto el agua se moverá de izquierda a
derecha pero en este vídeo pensaremos de
manera cuantitativa en cuál será el
potencial del agua para ir de izquierda
a derecha para eso hablaremos de algo
llamado potencial hídrico que se denota
con la letra griega sí ahora bien por
convención el potencial hídrico del agua
pura destilada cuando está en un
contenedor abierto a presión atmosférica
estándar será es decir la aps y de mi
lado izquierdo será igual a 0 bares
aquí puedes ver que las unidades para el
potencial hídrico son las mismas
unidades que tiene la presión estamos
usando los bares pero podemos usar a
díaz atmósferas o alguna otra unidad
ahora bien cuál será el potencial
hídrico en el lado derecho bueno de
manera general podemos separar el
potencial hídrico en sub componentes y
los subcomponentes de los que casi
siempre hablamos aunque haya más son el
componente de vido absoluto y el
componente debido a la presión es decir
el potencial soluto y el potencial
presión ahora como está cámara derecha
está abierta a la atmósfera y recibe una
presión atmosférica estándar el
potencial presión en este caso será
igual a cero por lo tanto todo el
potencial hídrico en el lado derecho se
obtiene del potencial soluto ahora bien
para encontrar nuestro potencial soluto
usaremos una fórmula
voy a poner por aquí una oca que
obtuvimos del college board donde nos
muestran una fórmula que necesitamos
para resolver la prueba de biología del
examen ap podemos ver que esta fórmula
es muy intuitiva y está relacionada con
la idea de los gases ideales que
estudiaste en química está fórmula nos
dice que el potencial soluto es igual a
menos y en un momento veremos qué
significa por nuestra concentración
molar cee por la constante de los gases
ideales r que a veces en este contexto
se llama la constante de presión pero es
la misma r que estudiamos en la ley de
los gases ideales por la temperatura en
el bid es decir por t
entonces esto será igual a primero
empecemos con like observa todo esto
será negativo por este signo ya que
todas estas cantidades son valores
positivos
es la constante de ionización una forma
de pensarlo es que para cada molécula en
el soluto cuántas moléculas se disocian
cuando las pones en el agua sabemos que
si ponemos una molécula de cloruro de
sodio en el agua ésta se disocia en
iones de sodio e iones de cloro o dicho
otra manera cada molécula de cloruro de
sodio se disocia en dos millones por lo
tanto aquí nuestra constante de
ionización será 2 ahora cuál será
nuestra concentración molar bueno ya lo
sabemos la concentración es 0.5 molar o
podemos escribirla como 0.25 moles por
litro
y a esto lo multiplicaremos por la
constante de presión o la constante del
gas ideal que es 0.0 831 litros por
bares entre moles porque el bid
y esto lo tendremos que multiplicar por
la temperatura en kelvin cuál sería
bueno a nuestros 21 grados celsius le
sumaremos 273 para obtener la
temperatura en que él viene 21 más 273
es 294 kelvin ahora esto será
aproximadamente igual a tenemos el signo
negativo que no hay que olvidar y si
observamos nuestras unidades los moles
se eliminan lo mismo con los litros y lo
mismo con los grados kelvin por lo tanto
nuestras unidades serán los bares lo
cual tiene sentido ya que son las
unidades con las que estábamos
trabajando así que sacaremos nuestra
calculadora y voy a multiplicar 2
0.25 y a esto lo voy a multiplicar por 0
punto 0 831 ya esto lo voy a multiplicar
por 294
y me da de resultado sí redondeamos a
sólo un decimal a 12.2 sin olvidar el
signo negativo esto es aproximadamente
menos 12.2 bares por lo tanto nuestro
potencial soluto que teníamos acá arriba
es de menos 12 punto dos bares y esto
nos da el total del potencial hídrico
porque el potencial presión es igual a
cero
ahora como interpretamos esto bueno una
forma de verlo es que como obtuvimos un
potencial negativo en comparación al
lado izquierdo entonces este lado atrae
el agua hacia él si esta membrana es
permeable sólo al agua entonces irá de
un alto potencial a un potencial más
bajo y eso fue justo lo que pensamos que
pasaría de una manera intuitiva ahora
otra cosa importante en la cual tenemos
que pensar es como evitaríamos que el
agua fluya bueno para eso podríamos
sumar un potencial presión
este lado tal vez podríamos agregar un
pistón y aplicar una presión para tener
una presión más alta a la presión
atmosférica pero cuánta presión debemos
de aplicar hacia abajo en esta cámara de
tal manera que no tengamos una entrada
neta de agua de la izquierda a la
derecha bueno imagina que aplicamos una
presión de 12.2 bares entonces este
potencial presión no sería cero sería
12.2 positivo pero sabemos que a la
derecha hay un potencial soluto de menos
12.2 si a esto le sumamos 12.2 del
potencial presión entonces tendríamos un
potencial hídrico de 0 en cuyo caso
tanto el lado izquierdo como el derecho
tienen el mismo potencial hídrico y por
lo tanto no tendremos una entrada neta
de agua en ninguna dirección puedes ver
que esta idea del potencial hídrico nos
permite pensar de una manera más precisa
o cuantitativa
ideas de ósmosis y tonicidad en fin nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo